und die sehen ohne scheiß ich sage das
jetzt einmal so knallhart wir sind ohne
schweiz selber so aus wie die letzte
mülltonnen ist einfach so er wird fast
gedacht jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen
video ich glaub ich hab euch bei logos
bei mir in der zweite teil war das
glaube ich habe ihn gefragt ja habt ihr
bock dass ich meinen autos bei jungs so
ein bisschen auf ziele zumal es auch ein
bisschen schwer ist weil ich selber jung
bin auf jeden fall habe ich mir ein
bisschen gedanken darüber gemacht und
ich habe mir so ein paar rausgesucht mit
vielen echt mega viele ein
deswegen gibt zwar schön doch davon
waren zweiten teil gibt einfach doch
nach oben weist wieder bescheiden so auf
jeden fall wünsche euch viel spaß mit
dem video und jetzt mache ich so 32 eis
so läuft und dann will ich mal sagen wir
fangen punkt nummer eins an ich muss
dabei ohne scheiß immer wieder erneut
lachen ich sehe es auch ab und zu mal
weil ich mit den komischerweise auf
facebook befreundet bin oder so und zwar
so dass irgendwelche jungs die posten
bilder von sich oberkörper verhalten
die posten bilder von sich oberkörper
frei und das problem ist nur die haben
gar keine muskeln dann denkt man sich
sowas ich bitte falsch wird ihr warum
postulat du wirst und deswegen nur
ausgelacht oder nicht ja doch bestimmt
alle schon mal ein bild gesehen wo ihr
euch gedacht habt schämst du dich nicht
oder so ich weiß es nicht also ich würde
es niemals machen so und dann jetzt ganz
schnell der zweite punkt und zwar habe
ich das auch so half schon mal einnetzte
new beantwortet was mit meinem kumpel
geht räder da irgendeine mädchen gefragt
warum tragen jungs der hochtief und mein
zweites bürger wäre dass es so viele
jungs gibt die zehnjährige holen so
richtig hoch so extrem hoch und dann ich
weiß ich dass ich einfach scheiße aus
ich kann euch immer im bild 1 von
irgendwem und der meinte es hat auch
ernst und es ich weiß nicht ob das
normal findet aber ich finde es sieht
einfach nur total bekloppt aus ich weiß
jetzt gar nicht ob ich überhaupt ein
bild finden werde aber schon mal so im
nachhinein ihr kennt doch bestimmt auch
alle so einen jungen der seine sporthose
da keine ahnung was bisher trägt und so
dann kommen jetzt auch schon zu punkt 3
und zwar an geht das so etwas mehr an
die etwas jüngeren jungs die noch nicht
allzu oft das wort respekt gehört haben
auf jeden fall lese ich das auch
auch unter meinen eigenen fotos auf
instagram da wird irgendwie einfach
beleidigt von diesen jüngeren kindern
die mich auf ihr vista ankotzen von
wegen ja irgendwas mit ihr äußeren sie
den scheiß außen so und dann gebt mir
mal selber auf das profil von diesem
verpackten bis mülltonnen und die seen
selber aus wie die letzten ich will
jetzt deinen worten ich denke ihr könnt
euch denken was ich damit sagen will und
ich wette ab auch überall schon mal so
wenige sehen der hat da fragt man sich
auch ja und dann sind wir jetzt auch
schon seit punkt x 24 erkennt auch alle
diese übelsten die übertragungs einfach
mit diesem fall aus triberg tun die hand
dann in puglia unter dem pulli kommt
noch so ein t shirt aus dass doch war
länger als der police und unter dem
t-shirt das eh schon länger als der
police komplott spiel heraus dass auch
länger als das t shirt ist was unter dem
pulli ist so und das war noch nicht
alles dann kommt man auch diese power
ranger stiefel die gehen bis zum knie da
können die gar nicht mehr ihre knie
knicken weil diese hoch sind und dann
machen die noch irgendwie so ein
aufsehen erregten
ich weiß ich wie es nennen soll auf
jeden fall die kette bestimmt auch so
den ein oder anderen der so rumläuft
oder habt ihr schon mal gesehen okay ja
ich weiß nicht dazu passt dann auch
eigentlich noch so ganz gut die jungs
wie ich gerade
ich bin ehrlich mir stinkt es jetzt
nicht so unglaublich gut wenn ich ein
foto machen und die cap wieso auf
absagen gemacht und dann so ein foto
machen aber auf wie der letzte
hampelmann diese jungs die einfach caps
trat aber diese caps ihn überhaupt ich
stehen davon gibt es auch eine menge ich
sehe davon auch immer wieder welche ja
und ich persönlich mache ich jetzt auch
nicht mehr so gerne mir so ein käppi
auszusetzen und damit video zu drehen
weil ich es im endeffekt bin ich das
video schreitet ich finde ich sehe damit
irgendwie beschissen aus ich weiß nicht
wie ihr das wie ich habe euch schon mal
gefragt aber ich habe es jetzt nur
gemacht was er heute irgendwie ich war
beim für solche sie ein bisschen kurze
auslandsumsätze doch mal wieder eine
auch ansonsten hab ich ja eben schon
gesagt wir würden noch viele weitere
autos einfach mal so wenn ihr bock auf
teil 2 hat in näherer zukunft geht
einfach noch nach oben und ansonsten
twitter
instagram ihr alles schön verlinkt könnt
ihr auch mal die beschreibung abchecken
hier auf der linken seite geht's weiter
mit meinem besten dinge die mädchen an
jungs verstehen mit einem kumpel so eine
special edition sag mal und hier auf der
anderen seite kommt jetzt nur noch auf
bei mädchen
der zweite teil aber nicht vergessen
wenn ihr nichts mehr verpassen wollt und
wir sehen uns dann am samstag wieder
oder am sonntag haut rein